as you may have heard the first
presidential debate is coming up it's
next Tuesday it'll air right here on Fox
News immediately following this show
tonight there are new calls for Joe
Biden not to show up from Democrats skip
it Joe Biden they're saying Fox Say Rick
lethal has been following that story and
Joints us tonight with the latest hey
Rick hey Tucker house Speaker Nancy
Pelosi doubling down on her suggestion
Joe Biden not debate president Trump
next Tuesday as scheduled not that I
don't think he'll be excellent she said
of Vice President Joe Biden uh she told
CBS that President Trump has no Fidelity
to fact or truth the California
Democrats suggested the debates might
become quote an exercise in skull
duggery here are some of her earlier
comments I don't think that there should
be any debates I do not think that the
president of the United States has
comported himself in a way that anybody
and that has any association with truth
evidence data and facts I wouldn't I
wouldn't
legitimize a conversation with
him today Nancy Pelosi said why bother
he doesn't tell the truth referring to
president Trump she also said the
president is a danger to democracy of
course the very first presidential
debate of this season Tucker is next
Tuesday night here on Fox with our own
Chris Wallace
moderating Rick lethal thanks for that